Boris Johnson has insisted Britain is
first in line for a trade deal with the
United States the foreign secretary
briefed the Commons on his return from
Washington where he spoke to senior
Republicans and Trump advisors praising
the president elects agenda for change I
had to say to the house that those a
huge fund of goodwill for the United
Kingdom in on Capitol Hill and a very
large measure of understanding that now
is the time to do a free trade deal they
want to do it they want to do it fast
and that that understanding was most
vivid and most urgent on the part of the
are the incoming administration there
should the uirr
UK be concentrating on the u.s. earlier
I spoke to mr. Johnson's conservative
colleague James cleverly who's
co-authored a paper today arguing for
increased trade with the Commonwealth
hosts brexit post customs union we have
an opportunity to strike free trade
deals globally and our argument is that
whilst the EU and the US are obvious
targets the Commonwealth represents a
pool of 2.3 billion people some of the
fastest-growing economies in the world
and a lot of the Member States of the
Commonwealth are in a place where they
are very ready to do business with us
one of your main assumptions here is
that the UK leaves the customs union
isn't that going to upset all those car
makers that supposedly been getting
assurances from the government that
they're going to be ok post brexit we've
not taken an explicit position on the
customs union III I think the the the
thinking generally is that striking free
trade deals is dependent on us leaving
customs union but we're in uncharted
territory and and if the government can
strike a deal where we can you know
maintain partial membership or associate
membership of them then that's fine the
point that we're saying is that if
international trade deals are going to
be done and I very much hope they are
that some of our Commonwealth partners
are obvious candidates for early free
trade agreements isn't it the case
though that with trade you're more
likely to do trade with people who are
on your doorstep which for the UK means
countries in the EU rather than
countries like Australia which it
halfway around the world yeah the the
gravity model the the proximity model of
trade is legitimate without a shadow of
a doubt and we're not suggesting in the
paper that we do a single Commonwealth
wide free trade deal because I think
that's impractical in the immediate
foreseeable future but what we are
saying is that the scale of economies
like Australia New Zealand Singapore
India for example mean that it's well
worth the investment in that extra
mileage to get these free trade deals
and we're not suggesting we do this
instead of deals with our European
partners this is as well as rather than
instead of